she has the skills to be a ninja
superstar give me the camera come on
come on come on you're on that way
Nina's looking at all the food and wants
to eat everything yeah she wants to try
everything I'm so lucky heaven is on the
world tour as they say happy wife happy
life come on stomach step up sponsored
the vlogs
is our last day in London oh you big
smiles in my face how is it going home
soon good times
how'd you sleep better than expected so
we're going to we are going to look for
a place to crap and then start our day
here in London we had a little walk in
today to get to our first destination so
we're gonna get our feet ready - my feet
my calves were killing you're gonna woke
up are you okay yeah my guys are killing
from all the walk we did I guess this
whole week but feeling good now so here
we go last day take a look at this guy
so blue if you guys have been following
along on this ship you know we've been
rained on every single day even
yesterday in London was not supposed to
rain and they found the way they get us
soaked he does not pay attention because
there's dogs they were playing she mrs.
Teemo so every time she sees a dog she
freaks head but today is super sunny and
bright not supposed to rain until about
6 o'clock so we're gonna enjoy this day
they're in the distance because
Westminster Abbey it's exciting because
the third time that I've tried to get
into Westminster Abbey since we've been
here on three different days the first
day was closed it was a Sunday you
couldn't get in second day we had
luggage and you not allowed to bring in
luggage
it's our third day and I'll have a
backpack now as long as they don't think
Nina is some terrorist I didn't say that
Wow okay well yes as long as they don't
think Nina's a terrorist and I will be
able to get in she has the skills to be
a ninja superstar but if you're on her
good side she's cute as a kid just just
don't get on her bad side but then it's
dangerous and I feel bad for you
Westminster Abbey here we go
no photography guys so this is as far as
I can take you all right we're done
would you think Nina
different get the walk on dead people
it's kind of
scary kind of creep being scary I try to
walk around it yeah I liked it has been
awhile since I've been there so it was
good you've already been to the shop so
let's go next stop next stop I don't
know
I'm gonna check my map and then we'll
figure out the next step
so next we're going to hop on a boat we
are going to take a tour of the river
and head out to the other side of London
which we haven't seen yet
Nina's gonna get some new stuff do you
think you're looking over into the clean
water look at that clean brown water
amazing we're back kind of boat Nina
okay do you think this is a lot slower
moving now get your sea legs back this
wheel generates 250,000 pounds in one
day
Rilla fortune
under the tunnel of
I spy with my little eye something that
is green green and white it's a star box
Nina's gonna get her drink very exciting
I really need to get Starbucks to
sponsor these vlogs we spend a lot of
air time here and money at Starbucks go
inside Mike step up sponsor the vlogs
all right Nina here's our coffee Cheers
yeah nice all right let's go okay next
up we're gonna hit the burrows market
this is a good place to eat supposedly
local food fresh stuff street food so
we're gonna go check it out we're
getting hungry we've got this double the
silver sitting is to get too angry well
we wait you don't feed the Nina she'll
feed on you so she's got her snack I'm
Annina to see that I'm Annina to and
we're gonna go to Berlin I don't think
I've ever been here either so that's
gonna be a purse for me we'll find some
yummy food and make the wife happy
because they say happy wife all right so
to get to the borough market we have to
cross London Bridge
Borana right now you guys know that song
when the bridge is falling down falling
down falling down right that time that's
the bridge run they made that song
because this bridge has been destroyed
and rebuilt four or five different times
there was a fire one time we was sinking
I don't member all the different reasons
but hopefully as we cross it it doesn't
fall down it's okay I will save you Nina
although you should see Nina in the
water I shall get on my back and then
strangle me like hands on the shoulders
shoulders not the neck anyway London
Bridge
take us to Borough Market
Nina's looking at all the food and wants
to eat everything she wants to try
everything you got a pic Nina your
stomach your eyes are big but your
stomach is tiny so you got to pick
something even I can't finish everything
for you a sample of everybody's Nina got
the sampler you want a whole bowl of it
maybe Nina you have to decide at some
point she has a food reader she knows
that there's three places that we missed
there go check a she's still sucking on
that spoon from we're at the world bud
shop I'm gonna try some sea salt caramel
but oh yeah I'll have to get some all
right we're gonna get some sea salt
caramel and clotted cream fudge I'm
gonna eat most of it
Nina's Lena's pretending like she's
eating it but that's gonna be me tonight
yeah tomorrow breakfast yeah I'm so
excited to eat this fudge but it's not
the reason we came here this is side
benefit Nina needs to get her lunch
they suggested meat pies and meat pies
and falafel that was the other one meat
pies and falafel you want to try both
meat pies impossible what about that
thing that you taste it if you love okay
you know what let's let's buy one meat
pie and they don't like it you go back
to get the campus all right deal
here we are traditional pies in marriage
award-winning pies
that's a lot of gravy I love it okay now
let's go was the potatoes you don't even
get the reaction that you had with the
Mexican paia though we don't we going
back and getting some of that yeah nice
all right good a happy Nina makes for
happy Evan
all right Nina what's next laughs oh I
am burger
she's too busy getting every last bit of
mashed potatoes
all right Nina decided she wants the pea
we're gonna go back
did you see the reaction in her face you
see how much it brought her to life I
love making the wife happy got a plan
some things every time I go on a trip
for the wife it doesn't always work out
but when it does you see the big smile
makes it all worth it chicken seafood
chorizo
all right let's see if it tastes just as
good the second time around I hope so
she goes put that in there Nina look at
the steam coming up
yeah I love it
all right we are done Nina's very happy
she likes these kind of markets she kind
of wishes we could be here all day long
do a workout come back eat some more try
more food next up we're gonna go to see
sage hopefully one of my contacts there
they're very close to here it's where my
contacts there suggested we try Mon
mouth coffee
we saw the message too late but we found
my mouth coffee we're gonna get him a
coffee instead or not cuz that line up
is crazy it is an out the door line up
for Mon mouth coffee so I think we're
gonna skip it and just go see sage sorry
there Daryl we wanted to get you the
coffee's a nice surprise
but the once ended up like either you
haven't seen Nina when she's in a lineup
turns very angry all right off to sage
thank you for visiting the Borough
Market
so sage is in that tall building that's
called the shard because it looks like a
shard of glass at the top they said it's
the tallest building in Western Europe
something like that so we call to go up
and see and sage has been a client of
mine for the past couple of years make
great accounting software I use them in
my business and we're gonna do I don't
know we're gonna say hi to Daryl Daryl
is in charge other social media and
maybe do a quick tour see the office
I've never actually been to their office
here in London this is our headquarters
a really prestigious location here so
I'm pumped to go in and say hi
mr. Darrell west there he is good man Oh
Daryl Nina this is where the hangouts
happened guys every month this is where
the hangouts happened
this is Stephens office he doesn't have
an office he just sits here with what
with everybody else that's the official
big boss chair right there
okay guys this is a sage strategy top
secret book on the wall I'm not that
secret okay revolutionary here we go
customers for life winning in the market
revolutionized business like that
capacity for growth and one stage there
you go the five pronged sage strategy
look at this guys we got hashtag belief
happening here we got a ton of believes
here look we got another believe here we
got another believe here there's another
one here I believe customers rule
hashtag believe I like it there he is
mr. Stephen Kelly how you doing this is
my wife Nina Nina Steven
we really wanted to go next door Steven
I really want to go next door because
that's where the magic happens for our
hangouts that's the room we should have
a clock this is the side of the room
guys that's where it happens we should
have London is it one of the greatest
cities in the world probably up there
with Toronto and summer the other great
cities and I'm so lucky heaven is on a
world tour and it started in London
Jennifer and Evan Carmichael the spirit
of entrepreneurs around the world
fantastic social medias done Canada
really young species champion of oneness
so this is my first time here which is
awesome I've been to London number of
times but it's great to see the place
the team with someone of your eyes to
end up in the bus stop
oh wow so we're in the bus stop and
waiting for a bus and like it's one of
those rolling they have like three or
four different eyes at a prime and so
like we're watching watches and boom
stage pops up it's like show me my Nina
what's your so far by the memory of
London you really carry come on come on
come on you're on that way
London's very different like the
architects they're so different from
what I have seen and the food I'm a
foodie
I love try all different kind of food
especially the international ones and
and I love the local food I love to try
the local food and the people people are
very nice yeah keep it coming in to see
it since I gave you about equal time out
on your trip around on your them with
the business schedule today that's great
alright we're done with sage that was
fun yeah how'd you like Stephen and it
can take very energetic yeah it's a good
match to me we both have our energies
going hey Nina got to be on the vlog got
some questions on the spot that was good
yes she got nervous she got she was
turning red
it's very exciting I love that okay and
she also got her mugs
she loved the sage mug so Steven went on
it Steven went on a personal mission
across the whole office to find two mugs
just for Nina yeah okay so you better
enjoy those two mugs Nina use them every
day I think of Steven and our trip to
London every time you drink